bonjour et merci d'être avec toi sur rt
france comment jugez-vous aujourd'hui la
position la posture de washington
la peinture de washington est le constat
d'un échec comme d'autres puissances ont
tenté de après le même genre de
politique qu'ont fait d'autres grandes
puissances en afghanistan a plu vous les
rues 79,89 3-4 ans est une circonstance
y laisser derrière eux un régime qui
était beaucoup plus modernistes si vous
voulez que ce qu'on avait soutenu en
occident puisqu'on a soutenu que les
forces les plus réactionnaires et le
pays a éclaté entre chefs de guerre et
les talibans sont apparus comme un
facteur de paix il faut se rappeler de
ces épisodes là c'est à dire que
l'afghanistan reste un pays à structure
technique si vous voulez dans lesquels
les chefs de guerre continue à gérer
leur propre territoire est clairement
leur propre territoire et donc en
éventuellement se faisant la guerre en
faisant du trafic etc puisque la
corruption évidemment du régime donc ce
régime est difficilement défendable
d'une manière générale les arguments ne
connaissent pas les bénéfices toute aide
américaine a été probalement détournés
par des gens qui sont proches du pouvoir
donc encore une fois les talibans
apparaissent plutôt comme des purs et
comme les gens qui vont d'une certaine
manière aboutir à se faire cesser les
violences ils vont aussi le pont comme
sable le fait que le président bush et
décider s'ils voulaient après les
attentats du 11-septembre non pas d'en
rire la salle arabie saoudite mais
d'envahir le look à distance qu'au fait
que ce pays est toujours considérée
depuis 79 vous rendez compte ça fait
plus de 40 45 presque cinquante ans que
ce pays est en guerre - toute force qui
apparaîtra comme une force de paix si
vous voulez sera soutenue pour les
avions mais alors comment est ce que
vous expliquez malgré tout cette avancée
cette offensive qui est si rapide elle a
été lancée au mois de mai en quelques
semaines finalement ils ont obtenu un
certain nombre de capitales provinciales
de quel soutien à ce qu'il bénéficie
comment ce finance-t-il est ce que le
pakistan est derrière cette offensive
toute façon que le pakistan ait soutenu
effectivement les talibans c'est une
évidence depuis très longtemps n'oubliez
pas que vous avez une contrainte qui
s'appelle la guerre globale contre le
terrorisme dans lequel des pays qui peut
traiter puis dictatoriaux de la planète
sont considérés comme des alliés s'ils
prétendent combattre le terrorisme c'est
un peu le cas du pakistan et le pakistan
simultanément ecobank d'aider les
talibans juste à côté parce que vis à
vis de ce rapport avec la galice en
constitue le commandeur l'arrière fond
stratégique donc ils ont eu une
politique afghane pratiquement depuis 79
ils ont alimenté toutes les formes de
violence en afghanistan depuis
l'invasion soviétique et ça c'est
toujours poursuivi est donc bien
évidemment le pakistan et la zone si
vous voulez le soutien principal de la
schl il reste l'autre part que beaucoup
des talibans si vous la ont été formés
dans des écoles coraniques qui avait été
ouvert par l'arabie saoudite à l'époque
de l'occupation soviétique avec le
soutien des occidentaux et donc les
talibans sont aussi un produit de
l'arabie saoudite et des stupidités du
soutien occidental si vous voulez à la
lutte antisoviétique donc on se retrouve
aujourd'hui piégé par une force on a
aidé à constituer
sur le thé cette force était très
probablement soutenue par la population
encore une fois parce qu'elle promet la
paix la justice la lutte contre les
corrompus etc sur le front sur le
terrain concernant les combats est ce
que vous direz que kaboul est sur le
point de tomber aux mains des talibans
qu'attends tu vraiment les insurgés pour
s'attaquer à la capitale afghane
écoutez je ne connais pas l'importance
de leur force c'est à dire jusqu'à
maintenant ils ont été relativement
prudents même si la chose paraît très
impressionnante sur le terrain est-ce
qu'ils sont en mesure d'attaquer l'île
capitale avec tous est quand même il ya
une masse de réfugiés il ya probablement
tous les moyens de défense concentrés
autour de kaboul ça je ne peux pas le
dire mais on voit bien avec des
démissions qui se succèdent aux coups
avec des désertions plo cap l'armée que
kaboul peut très bien tomber comme un
fruit mûr de bain et encore une fois il
faut s'interroger encore occidentaux sur
l'eau l'utilisation de l'intervention
militaire comme moyen de résoudre une
crise encore une fois on les a toutes
alignées et c'est à dire les anglais
ceux ci se sont cassé les dents aux
derniers siècles et russe se sont cassé
les dents milieu du xxème siècle mais
américain se casse les dents dans ce
genre de crise parce qu'encore une fois
un missionnaire armée personne même sa
personne il faut qu'avec l'accord le
type apparaissent comme une composante à
logan et c'est la principale force des
talibans ils sont afghans autorités
afghanes auraient donc proposé aux
insurgés lors des négociations qui se
déroulent au qatar un accord de partage
du pouvoir en échange
l'arrêt des violences est ce que c'est
ce que veulent les talibans qu'est ce
qu'ils cherchent aujourd'hui
l'état n'est les talibans probablement
se demande quel est le degré de
résistance que qu'est capable d'opposer
la la le capi de la capitale le régime à
en placer une volée donc les temps que
ça marche ils vont continuer à imprimer
de privilégier l'offensive militaire
menée continuer à négocier ces données
se donner une bonne à dire une bonne
bonne façade mais je doute je doute
qu'ils aient l'intention de partager le
pouvoir s'ils peuvent le prendre ils le
prendront elles après il faut en tirer
les conclusions c'est à dire après il
faudra se dire qu'est ce qu'on fait si
un régime taliban à kaboul alors vous
l'avez évoqué mais on a parlé également
de la déroute des forces régulières
afghanes comment est ce que vous vous
l'expliquer c'est essentiellement un
manque de moyens
non c'est certainement un manque de
moyens parce que je fais confiance aux
américains pour leur fournir tout ce
qu'on peut leur fournir mais ça rappelle
étrangement si vous voulez la
déliquescence du régime je dis bien si
rouler à partir d après les accords de
paris c'est à dire que on a vu une armée
cette vitamine qui était largement
équipés par les américains et qui sait
quand même crouler si vous voulez selon
le de face aux mines et aux forces du
nord guetta donc on est dans ce genre de
situation encore une fois en tant
qu'occidentaux en puissance si vous
voulez légitimité qu'on se donne à une
intervention militaire on se la donne
pour nous mêmes on ne tient pas compte
de la situation locale si les aînés au
fil à reconnaître que l'afghanistan est
un pays musulman dans lequel pour être
avoir une quelconque consistance
politique il faut être musulman même si
on est un pays étranger on se rend bien
compte que nous n'avons pas cette
légitimité donc cessons de croire
qu'avec un peu de moyens militaires on
reprendrait faire c'est certainement
l'oeuvre la maîtrise si vous laissiez
ont refusé une nouvelle offensive
occidental mais encore une fois à
regarder la catastrophe depuis 2001
depuis pratiquement 20 ans on a fait
plus le double si vous voulez contre
l'occupation soviétique donc commençons
à reconsidérer l'idée que la coop des
certaines crises peuvent se gérer une
intervention militaire même si la
supériorité technologique est avéré le
processus de négociation est un
appendice de tout ça merci beaucoup pour
votre analyse pierre conesa ancien haut
fonctionnaire spécialiste des questions
stratégiques internationales